that said
you've also showed appreciation for the
greatest language
um ever that i think everyone agrees
is lisp um well this was definitely on
my list of the greatest ones that have
have um existed is that number one or
i mean um are you i mean
you know that you know the thing is that
it's that you you know
i wouldn't put it number one no is it
the parentheses what uh
um what do you love what do you
not love about lisp um
well i guess the number one thing to not
love about it is so freaking many
parentheses yeah um
on the on the love thing is you know out
of those
tons of parentheses you actually get an
interesting language structure
and i've always thought that there was a
friendlier version of lisp
hiding out there somewhere um
but i've never really spent much time
thinking about it thinking about it
you